quantum break releases very soon and  you'd think that would free up develop a  remedy to revisit the Alan Wake  franchise after the team trademarked  alan wake's return in February it seemed  all but confirmed but now we know just  what alan wake's return is and it's not  a new video game it's an in-game video  series you can watch with in quantum  break alan wake's return is a full-on  live-action miniseries starring sam lake  the creative director remedy the  copyright was made for legal purposes  remedy actually did the same thing for  its bright falls web series this is  definitely disappointing news for some  fans but on the other hand you will get  to see Alan Wake again in quantum break  speaking of which quantum break launches  for Xbox one and PC on april fifth for  now there's nothing to announce as far  as future Alan Wake games but hey stay  tuned to gamespot if remedy announces  anything we'll hear about it